for 25 years Sydney SAW has had one
nemesis the yellow fever mosquito the
insect is spreading especially in Brazil
transmitting diseases such as dengue
fever chikungunya and now the Zika virus
the number of infections has seen a
dramatic increase and the w-h-o is
alarmed puddles are a major problem as
mosquitoes lay their eggs there Sydney
saw is on a mission to educate warn and
raise awareness will she and her team
managed to rid Brazil of this plague
I
so once again for everyone so we don't
forget we're here to eradicate our
beloved mosquito
so please please don't just take care of
your own homes water tanks speak to
people this is a war and we have to win
so let's find a loot that one was a gay
time to deploy Sydney saw and her team
in the fight against the epidemic in the
Brazilian state of says she pay 70
employees are on their way from village
to village house-to-house since December
when Zika hit the headlines the military
has joined in efforts commanded by the
country's President every empty yogurt
pot every can is a potential breeding
ground for mosquitoes it's a great thing
for us soldiers have Authority and
protect our people if and when someone's
unhappy about our visit today's visit
takes them to the outskirts of a small
inland town they're inspecting the home
of Manuel Santos he recently suffered
from the painful shaquan gloomy fever
transmitted by the yellow fever mosquito
this is terrible really awful a yellow
fever mosquito has everything it needs
here to thrive an open washing tank and
here the dogs water bowls are just lying
around uncovered come here please I want
to show you something you see those
small things jerking about those are
yellow fever mosquito larvae and soon
there will be actual mosquitoes you see
and they carry dengue and chikungunya
fever which you had yourself and the
Zika virus to look how easily you can
destroy the mosquito eggs look it's so
easy you're here to help us with health
problems right but we need your help
we're here today but we won't be
tomorrow
I do do that all the time but I'm a
widower I live alone I just want to say
that sometimes there isn't time under
Sydney's watchful eye Manuel Santos has
to prove that he can scrub it himself
people know the precautions they just
don't stick to them it's really typical
we see it every day and also Tina and I
said yeah they go to the next house and
it's a dump this is a full-blown
mosquito party the whole toilet is full
of larvae I'd really like to know why
some people want to live like this it's
a lack of education and poor upbringing
and I feel bad for them if we don't
steer Brazil in the right direction
quickly then nothing will change as far
as the mosquito situation is concerned
the yellow fever mosquito is said to be
present across 80% of Brazil that's four
times more than a decade ago every
single drop that falls in here can bring
mosquitos so turn everything over but
think of all the coconuts in Brazil all
the backyards the breeding potential for
mosquitoes is almost endless Sydney
sounds work against the epidemic has
never been more crucial for a good part
of my day I'm basically married to the
mosquito a large part of my life too
actually when my son was growing up I
missed a lot by say
he say now he's already a young man I've
devoted my life to the yellow fever
mosquito I've studied them and learned
how to fight them a ladakh or mosquito
there's one major problem in the fight
though the mains water in the region is
often out for days so there are water
tanks everywhere uncovered a paradise
for mosquitoes Sydnee repeats her simple
message to the residents of this house
years of campaigning and more recent
appeals against Zika seem to go
unnoticed out here in the countryside we
really need help something different we
need new techniques innovations it's
inevitable to make sure no more babies
are born with these problems Gideon says
no baby wanna see microcephaly is a
condition that's gripped world headlines
special consultations are held in this
hospital in Eric Azul the state capital
of says she Bay there are 50 times more
babies born with a brain that's too
small compared to last year la yaani
is almost four months old all signs
indicate that her mother had Zika during
pregnancy but there are no tests yet in
Sochi Bay
it's a four-hour drive to her parents
village since the baby was born Danny
Santos and her farmer husband Joe are
struggling to make ends meet
little la yaani needs attention around
the clock we're constantly driving to
Erica last time I came back so shattered
that I couldn't sleep everything hurt
looking after our little one is a daily
struggle but her health comes first for
us okay pour these water tanks are
covered just as they should be even long
before my pregnancy we've always made
sure not to leave any water standing
around scared of mosquitoes if I see one
I kill it straight away still in the
yard just a few meters away trash and
bottles are the perfect breeding ground
for yellow fever mosquitoes it's not
right I know that really I need to throw
that away and that should be turned over
the local health center can't offer much
help Sydney saws task force have never
been out here before said Sheba is the
size of Israel so Sydney has to opt for
spot checks
she takes daily trips into the depths of
the country with her assistant of eight
years driver Antonio
wait'll he's my companion in the worst
of battles isn't that right buddy we've
already worked together on a massive
dengue epidemic sir charisma
that's why they all love to work with
her they arrive in the next small town
these soldiers are always a welcome help
for Sidney beautiful all in uniform so
nicely disciplined what more do you want
in this community there's more hope than
despair the local awareness campaigns
have triumphed all they need here is
guidance not parenting most houses are
mosquito-proof and this house has a
dengue free sticker for all to see
the last stop of the day is a visit to
this pregnant woman when the information
about microcephaly and Zika came out
that was the start of your pregnancy
right I was in my fourth month but I
wasn't too worried the nurse made me
really scared she advised me to coat
myself in mosquito repellent immediately
but always continued to take precautions
around the house you need to be careful
especially because your baby son will
soon be here but for today no complaints
a successful trip
ciao nobody god that's a then an urgent
message comes in from the Health
Ministry god there's something new every
day it's possible that the Zika virus is
contagious between humans I'm really
shocked by the news we've just got I
don't want to talk too much about it but
I can tell you that it's scary
one thing certain though the yellow
fever mosquito is transmitter number one
that's why I'd like to say well done and
thank you for your work take care and
see you next week ciao see you
I think Aida next week Sydney South
struggle goes on as she continues her
uphill battle against the mosquitoes one
small step at a time